we're learning much more about the
devastating impact of hurricane Nicole
she is now a tropical depression over
the South the storm slammed into
Florida's Atlantic Coast early yesterday
morning packing 75 mile an hour winds it
left Seaside homes crashing into the
ocean the storm is now being blamed for
at least four deaths Elise Preston is in
Daytona Beach where there is major
damage there Elise good morning to you
Gail good morning to you the major story
line here in Volusia County is the
effects of coastal erosion Nicole
brought destructive storm surge creating
waves as large as 16 feet tall the
shoreline already damaged by Hurricane
Ian just weeks ago couldn't hold up
this is what's left after Hurricane
Nicole battered Florida's eastern coast
swept the foundations from under
Beachside homes triggering widespread
collapse and ruin
communities in Daytona Beach Shores and
nearby Wilbur by the Sea were among the
hardest hit residents like property
manager Crystal Goodrich say living here
wasn't always such a risk we did not
build as if we were going to be
overlooking the ocean this was not an
area that has ever even flooded but this
time the remnants of some homes were
swept out to sea flood waters overtook
city streets heavy winds downed trees
and knocked down power lines at one
point more than 330 000 people were
without electricity Statewide our
infrastructure took a beating from
Hurricane there was no way that we could
have ever recovered from that and now
here comes Nicole Mike Chitwood is the
Volusia County Sheriff he called
hurricane Nicole a knockout punch and
said more than 600 people had been
evacuated from condos that were declared
structurally unsafe what's going through
your mind right now
I mean it's heartbreaking our Town's in
for some pretty hard times I think Marcy
Dutton has lived in Daytona Beach off
and on since the 1970s she used to sell
ice cream on the beach we are a tourist
town that beach is our life our lifeline
and when we no longer have that it's
going to affect the economy of this town
officials have called this structural
damage unprecedented they fear even more
buildings could collapse in the coming
days for that reason the county sheriff
has imposed a strict curfew he did all
day yesterday and through the night it
expired at seven this morning Nate
Elise thank you